hi everyone i am here in beautiful
budapest hungary filming the modern day
reimagining
of alice in wonderland called get lost
i'm so excited to be here
amazing cast amazing crew i can't wait
to share it with you guys
and i'll keep you posted that's ella
travolta john travolta's daughter
talking about her starring role in get
lost a modern day reimagining of alice
in wonderland
and no one is more excited than her dad
who posted this pic of his daughter to
instagram
and wrote here's my daughter ella
starring in a live-action reimagining of
alice in wonderland
called get lost i'm a very proud dad
and then i dared to put posted on my
instagram
john is clearly very supportive of
ella's acting dreams
in 2019 during an appearance on the talk
he
joked about being the ultimate stage dad
i'm ridiculous
i'm behind the camera mouthing every
word she says
doing her moves i just wanted to go
great at the time ella said she was
grateful to have her dad on sets with
her
as she started her acting career it
actually helped so much knowing that he
was there
and that after and he would come up in
between scenes
because i was in a car so he would come
in that was great oh my gosh
okay good and then i would know and i
would know that
there i had him behind the monitor just
watching and making sure it was all good
ella first starred in the 2009 flick old
dogs alongside her dad
and her mom the late kelly preston it
was a
first family project and disney was
generous enough to allow us to do
together and we had a fantastic time it
was new for me so i was a little scared
when i first did it but then i was like
yes this is so much fun yep e.t has been
with ella since the very beginning
tell me what's your favorite thing about
acting
um kind of everything and even then
over a decade ago it was clear the now
21 year old
loved acting i like the lines and stuff
you like rehearsing yeah and the
dialogue
i think ella loves dialogue that likes
the lines
fast forward to 2021 and the
father-daughter duo took the world by
storm in their super bowl commercial
together
recreating the iconic dance from john's
musical classic
greece
seems like it's just the beginning for
ella and like her dad we can't wait to
see
what she does next
you